well of course february is the month of
love and so many couples are seizing the
moment to tie the knot bianca holmen is
live at a dispensary for a unique way to
say i do bianca tell us more about all
these couples who are high on love
with these cannabis weddings
yeah who would have thought about this
well we're going to talk to the
mastermind behind these cannabis
weddings that are happening here in las
vegas at planet 13 but usually a vegas
wedding was elvis impersonator
the show girls now you got to add some
bud to that so i'm joined by maxine and
so you tell me about how you came up
with this idea well i had the las vegas
cannabis tours and everybody was asking
where can we get married with the
cannabis theme so that's how i invented
las vegas cannabis weddings and you also
officiate the weddings we just saw you
do the avow renewal with the couple jc
and leilani so tell us what is it
feeling like for you to do this with
those couples um well obviously it's
really a happy happy time and i love
doing what i do and i love connecting
people and remarrying them or of course
marrying them so i've married all sorts
of people and i love it okay and i
imagine these two these weddings of
course they have some munchies
afterwards i'm going to invite planet 13
summer thank you for joining us so tell
us how this partnership came about i
mean you all do it all here at planet
13. you have the willy wonka kind of
theme you got the restaurant yes well
love is in the era planet 13. so planet
13 is the perfect destination for an
unforgettable and unique cannabis themed
experience so we are so ecstatic to be
partnering with las vegas cannabis
weddings to offer this to the community
and those that are interested so it's a
one-stop shop at planet 13. sure and i
bet how you said you were telling me
that these weddings are booked out until
april yes they are we have some spaces
uh for 420 but um yep we've had so many
bookings and lots of receptions coming
up here at tressay at the restaurant
here at planet 13. we're super excited
perfect now who would've thought
dispensaries are now turning into
wedding chapels kind of i don't know if
we can add that to the list but
this definitely is something that only
happens in vegas back to you guys happy
valentine's day